Я - Лекстутес Юрій Олегович. Колишній міністр культури і туризму "ДНР".
Також брав активну участь у проведенні референдуму на території "ДНР".
Зараз знаходжуся в Україні.
З Юрієм Лекстутесом зустрічаємося біля Драмтеатру в Маріуполі.
Ексміністр самопроголошеної "ДНР" визнає: хоч і часто тут буває,
на вистави поки не ходив - забагато роботи.
За два роки після переїзду з окупованого Донецька за програмою повернення колишніх сепаратистів
"На тебе чекають вдома" він встиг побудувати успішний бізнес.
Займається ремонтом квартир, живе між Києвом і Маріуполем,
який ще кілька років тому в інтерв'ю російським ЗМІ називав окупованою територією.
- Вы сказали, что один из Ваших театров находится в Мелитополе на оккупированной территории.
- Не в Мелитополе, а в Мариуполе. Да, этот театр называется "Русский театр".
Находится на оккупированной территории.
До сепаратистів Юрій Лекстутес, який мав будівельний бізнес на Донеччині,
приєднався на початку 2014-го року. Він був одним із тих, хто стояв біля витоків самопроголошеної "ДНР".
- Це я в міністерстві у себе в кабінеті.
Пургін Андрій. Денис Пушилін. Роман Лягін. Ось я - позаду стою.
Коли у Києві почався Майдан, Янукович і Партія регіонів, які тоді
позиціонували себе як чинна влада,
почали збирати масові зібрання, свої Майдани у Харкові і Донецьку.
Якщо 7-8 чоловік навколо тебе кажуть на біле чорне,
ми теж повіримо, що це чорне. Тоді запрацювала серйозна машина пропаганди.
У принципі я вірив, що там відбувається якийсь переворот, а ми підтримуємо чинну владу.
Як це пояснювалося всьому населенню і мені, треба захищати свої домівки і тому подібне.
У так званій "російській весні" на Донбасі бізнесмен брав активну участь,
хоч і не зі зброєю в руках. Зокрема долучився до сепаратистського референдуму
у Докучаєвську. Каже, на організацію голосування витратили лише кілька тисяч гривень.
На принтері бюлетені друкували. Частину видали у виборчій комісії,
а іншу частину, якщо комусь там не вистачало, йшли і додруковували, і все.
Щось десь зіпсували, щось десь загубили, тобто по факту як до паперу ставилися.
Вже були конкретні цифри. Все інше просто красиво розіграли в медіа, десь людей підбурили.
А ви самі голосували?
Ні.
Тобто ви організовували, але самі не голосували?
Мені якось не до цього було.
Як міністр культури самопроголошеної "ДНР" Юрій Лекстутес організовував
гастролі артистів із Росії на окупованому Донбасі, спілкувався з російською пресою,
легітимуючи невизнані республіки. Нині він каже, що швидко розчарувався у так званій "ДНР".
Утім, шляху назад вже не було.
Зрозумів, що відбувається підміна всього, про що нам розповідали,
коли став отримувати більше доступу до інформації і побачив, як все відбувається.
Але на той момент мене вже "заплямували" у цій справі,
та й сам я туди встряг по самісіньке "не хочу". Тож, у принципі, вже довелося працювати.
Лекстутес каже, що неодноразово ставав на заваді спробам бойовиків пограбувати донецькі музеї.
Щоправда, на початку 2015-го року влада так званої "ДНР" звинуватила
його самого у тому, що він нібито "відтиснув" у донецьких театрів кілька автомобілів.
Сам Лекстутес стверджує: його хотіли усунути політичні конкуренти.
Після кількох місяців у Донецькому СІЗО він замислився, як виїхати на підконтрольну територію,
і вирішив скористатися програмою "На тебе чекають вдома".
Страх за життя при спробі залишити ту територію,
адже людей із моїм прізвищем на території колишнього Радянського Союзу всього четверо.
Я намагався спершу зрозуміти всі алгоритми. Не через те, що я настільки не довіряв
співробітникам СБУ. Я просто розумів, що стикаюся з іншими спецслужбами,
з якими я до цього неодноразово мав справу: із ГРУ, з місцевим МГБ.
Моя дружина їхала через лінію зіткнення. Жінка з трьома дІтьми не так привертала до себе увагу.
Навіть близькі родичі певних діячів звідти часто їздять в Україну чи навіть за кордон.
У мене ж зовсім інакше все було. Поки не буду розповідати,
думаю, ще багато людей захочуть повернутися сюди.
Проти Юрія Лекстутеса - на цьому відео він ще з закритим обличчям -
відкрили справу за статтею 258-3 - "Створення терористичної групи чи терористичної організації".
За це в Україні можна на 15 років сісти до в'язниці.
Проте суд звільнив ексміністра самопроголошеної республіки від відповідальності.
Це можливо, якщо людина "добровільно повідомляє про терористичну діяльність
та сприяє її припиненню".
Нормально зустріли. Протягом місяця провели слідство. Передали документацію в прокуратуру,
прокуратура передала в суд. Коли почався судовий розгляд, за пів години з мене зняли
кримінальну відповідальність.
Згодом Юрій Лекстутес все-таки отримав термін за участь у референдумі - з відстрочкою.
Тобто у в'язниці не провів ані дня. Так ексміністр самопроголошеної "ДНР" став одним
із близько 400 колишніх сепаратистів, яких за 5 років існування програми "На тебе чекають вдома"
звільнили від кримінальної відповідальності за тероризм.
Керівниця пресслужби Головного управління СБУ в Донецькій та Луганській областях Галина Прищепа
запевняє, що охочих насправді набагато більше. Проте їх ретельно перевіряють:
чи не вчинили тяжких злочинів.
Здебільшого це звичайні громадяни України, які у 2014 році з різних причин -
через безгрошів'я або відсутність роботи, через якісь
заманливі пропозиції, або піддавшись російській пропаганді -
ставали до лав незаконних збройних формувань. Мета програми - це допомогти учасникам
незаконних збройних формувань повернутися до мирного життя.
Таким чином ми робимо послугу і собі. Ми зменшуємо кількість
військових збройних формувань на окупованій території.
Я так розумію, що вони цікаві також як інформанти,
які можуть багато чого розповісти?
Наскільки це важливо?
Це вже оперативна робота, про яку ми говорити не можемо.
Але теоретично, якщо думати про це, то, мабуть, так.
Співпраця зі слідством є також однією з умов програми.
Колишній міністр так званої "ДНР" Юрій Лекстутес не приховує, що мав що розповісти спецслужбам.
Адже, як він неодноразово повторює в інтерв'ю, належав до "вищого ешелону влади"
в самопроголошеній республіці.
Я спілкувався з РФ і з усіма, хто зараз при владі на тому боці. Я достатньо знаю.
Є, мабуть, справ 50 кримінальних, де я проходжу як свідок. І в Україні, і в міжнародних судах.
Наприкінці минулого року Юрій Лекстутес почав вести відеоблог у Youtube.
Проводить інтерв'ю з такими ж колишніми сепаратистами, які скористалися програмою
"На тебе чекають вдома".
У мене є відчуття провини, через те, що мене обманули і я обманув інших.
Фактично я розповідав те, у що сам вірив. Приємно розуміти і бачити правду,
і дуже хочеться відкрити її іншим людям.
Щоправда, великого попиту на програму нині немає. Адже на тих, хто брав участь у реальних боях,
вона не розповсюджується. Крім того, дискредитувати ініціативу
всіма силами намагається й окупаційна влада: потенційних кандидатів лякають, що
на підконтрольній Києву території на них чекатимуть репресії.
Утім, такі повідомлення, хоч і поодинокі, трапляються і в поважних джерелах.
В останньому звіті ООН про права людини в Україні йдеться про випадок, коли чоловіку нібито
пообіцяли, що він може скористатися програмою, але згодом, вже після виїзду
на підконтрольну уряду територію, затримали і намагалися змусити погодитися
на обмін полоненими.
DW звернулася до СБУ з проханням прокоментувати інцидент, однак відповіді поки не отримала.
Тим часом правозахисники давно критикують програму за її закритість.
Цю закритість можна пояснити зокрема тим, що
імена цих людей і їхні історії не можна розголошувати, бо вони дуже вразливі.
Це правда. Але з іншого боку, це означає повну закритість цього процесу.
Бо все-таки це операція спецслужби, для якої, безперечно, одна з цілей - отримати від цих людей
потрібну їй інформацію. А як вона це робить, ми ж це не знаємо.
Є в потенційної цільової аудиторії програми й інші страхи. Дехто боїться, що переслідувань
зазнають їхні рідні, які залишаться на окупованій території.
Або ж елементарних побутових проблем, пов'язаних із пошуком житла і роботи на новому місці.
Утім, як би там не було, іншої можливості реінтеграції у колишніх сепаратистів наразі немає.